it's ridiculous how long these things to
make we we started developing the film
internally about it was probably about
like four or five years ago while we
were part way through production on
Coraline and and then in the actual
production took about two years you know
we talked about it as John Carpenter
meets John Hughes and there was
something very rich about that I wanted
to play in that world so over the years
when I was working on other projects I
kept going back in there I know that I'm
incredibly biased of course with stop
motion but I feel like I can tell the
difference with them touching these
puppets and moving them and that the
animation is just more and it's more
special it's more natural it's more
lifelike it's a little more charming you
know maybe then some of the alternatives
we see in CG and you're right it's a
one-shot deal you know like these guys
go into their sets and they perform
these shots they are performers these
animators and and it's a one-time moment
you know I mean it's already takes a
long time but it we capture that piece
of performance and then in some
repeatable it's common to start
production and not know what the ending
is and the story team is wild production
is going on is figuring out the third
act you know trying new ideas we didn't
have that approach on this we had a
fairly you know that the script was
pretty much locked which I think was
really useful to us because it gave us
the opportunity to to sit down at the
very beginning we knew where we were
headed we knew what the ending of the
movie was and we knew the tone of the
movie because of that and it enabled us
to sit down and really get on the same
page about the aesthetic and have a lot
of conversation about the the the
overall look of the movie and sometimes
I think you know you don't get as much
opportunity to spend time doing that at
the beginning because you're still
busily trying to figure out the story
yeah we are incredibly prepared because
you only get one chance really to shoot
the shot so you know everything are it's
this incredible series of details that
we get right so that on the day that
when you know the animator is there
shooting or let's
really the year that he might be
shooting or she might be shooting it's
right so the details like the ear you
know they we did a lot of research and
development with those materials and
found out that you know light would
shine through in a really realistic and
beautiful way it's not like a
live-action film we can go to a prop
house and just and just grab something
put it in the movie we have to build
everything from the ground up nothing
exists and so then it becomes because
you know we work on a small scale Norman
he's about you know nine and a half
inches tall that's always got to ask so
you have to find you know the right
sorts of materials in that world like he
wears denim jeans but you couldn't use
real denim for his jeans that I mean the
thread would give it away so you have to
find really thin materials and then
treat them and such a screen then print
them in such a way that makes them feel
and look like denim but you know his
hair it was made out of goat hair you
find these really weird materials to end
up using for these things the trees that
forest of trees those things were all
made out of corrugated cardboard and and
shredded paper was the ground cover so
it's just it's a bunch of just really
interesting uses of regular materials
that we then treat in such a way to make
it feel like it live naturally in this
world the scary side of it is something
that I think we're responsible about
responsible about because it's something
that we consider every day every day of
production it's it's in our minds you
know because the slightest thing can
overturn the balance and even from just
way back the writing point of view it
wasn't to make a horror movie for kids
it was to make this kind of supernatural
adventure that references horror motifs
and uses them and actually turns them on
their head but having said that I think
we all strongly believe that you know
scary stuff more challenging stuff it
should be part of children's fiction you
know it children's fiction has a rich
tradition of you know scary challenging
elements and I think you know there's a
purpose to that it's nothing new you
know it goes back to fairy tales and
certainly the kids movies that I grew up
watching the ones that had the biggest
impact on my on my brain was you know I
remember watching pinocchio being scared
no being scared by it I can't generalize
about kids who I don't think rather like
you can't generalize about people you
know
and so yeah they are incredibly complex
and sophisticated creatures and I we
didn't we never wanted to talk down to
two kids in this move no I think that's
the critical thing is that we certainly
are not we don't want to traumatize her
audience but we'd also don't want to
speak down to them we want to respect
their intelligence and their
sophistication and when you go back to
the you know the great family films in
history things like snow why they were
able to find or Pinocchio they were able
to find a really perfect balance of
darkness and light of intensity and
warmth and I think by having those two
kind of polar things that dynamic you're
able to tell a more powerful more
enriching story and by kind of evening
those levels out by if you're worried
about you know traumatizing the audience
it's like it just ultimate it i think
it's defeating on making a pout the most
powerful story you can